month our actions have hit the thing
president care about the most degrading
his military access to cutting edge
technology and ability to project power
and influence central bank reserves
about half of putin's war chest is
immobilized you heard the finance
minister confirmed this just yesterday
or the day before he can't use these
rainy day funds to support his war in
ukraine the ruble is less than a penny
it's the worst performing emerging
market currency
the russian stock market the stock
market has been closed for nearly three
weeks longest in his in its history as
they try to prevent a market crash
inflation in russia isn't rampant some
forecasters are predicting 20
inflation for russia by the end of the
year and the russian and trillions of
dollars in businesses have been
disrupted by
sanctions putting the russian financial
sector under severe stress the economic
look look at the economic outlook for
the country forecasters around the world
are projecting a collapse of the russian
economy institute for international
finance projects a 15 downturn down from
a projected growth rate of 3 before
russia's invasion of ukraine and the
private sector as many of you have
reported on is withdrawing many
companies major companies in the
financial energy and other sectors are
leaving jp morgan goldman sachs western
union exxon mobil shell and more are
pulling their operations out of the
country and as we continue to to ratchet
up pressure on putin's oligarchs wanted
to also announce free or reiterate for
you for those who already know the
tomorrow secretary of treasury janet
yellen and attorney general garland will
host the launch meeting of the russian
elite proxies and oligarchs
multi multilateral task force and the
task force was first announced in a
statement by leaders including president
biden on february 26 as a way to go
after corrupt gains from some of the
individuals closest to putin
no matter what where they're held around
the world and the task force comprised
of finance ministry and justice or home
ministry counterparts in germany canada
japan france italy australia the
european commission and the united
kingdom will use the respective
authorities to collect and share
information against russian targets
including sanctions asset freezing and
civil and criminal asset seizure let me
give you just a couple of examples of
assets that have already been seized
alexey mordachov's a 213-foot yacht was
impounded in italy gennady timchenko's
132 foot yacht was seized in italy andre
mel
melenchenko's 469 foot 578 million
dollar super yacht was seized in italy
sergey chemezov's 140 million dollar
yacht was seized in spain igor sections
280 foot yacht was impounded in france
and alice umanov's 18 million resort was
impounded in sardinia that is just the
beginning last thing i just wanted to
note sorry i have two quick things for
you and we'll get to the questions is on
ukrainian security assistance the
president will talk about this
when he speaks this afternoon and he
will talk about it more extensively
tomorrow as you know there is 13.6
billion dollars for ukraine humanitarian
security and economic assistance in the
omnibus bill that the president is going
to sign this afternoon he will outline
in more detail i expect tomorrow the
specifics but he will of course talk
about it when he signs it this afternoon
but just even up to date now since
taking office the president has
committed 1.2 billion dollars in
security assistance to ukraine including
550 million in just the last two weeks
we've approved he has approved four
emergency security assistance packages
to provide ukraine the types of weapons
they are using so effectively to defend
their country such as anti-armor and air
defense weapons uh we are working to get
ukraine the equipment as quickly as
possible and we're still mean to
continue doing that over the past two
weeks alone we have delivered more than
300 million dollars of security
assistance to ukraine in addition to the
transfers of us-made equipment we are
facilitating from our allies to ukraine
as well so i would note that we're on
day 19 here in addition to their
incredible courage and bravery one of
the reasons they are able to hold back
and push back against the russian
military is because of the significant
amount of military assistance we have
provided finally i just wanted to wanted
to note that today is equal pay day um
something we can all celebrate uh
president biden and vice president
harris have long championed equal pay as
a cornerstone of their commitment to
ensure all people have a fair and equal
opportunity to get ahead to mark equal
pay day today the biden harris
administration announced a couple of new
actions to promote women's empowerment
and support women's family women working
families across the country
the office of personnel management
announced that they will anticipate
issuing a proposed regulation that will
address the use of prior salary history
in the hiring and pay setting process
for federal employees the president will
sign an executive order directing the
federal acquisition regulatory council
to consider limiting the use of salary
information in employment decisions by
federal contractors and the department
of labor will release a report analyzing
the impact of occupational segregation
on women's economic security and the
vice president will host an event later
today along with the gender policy
council i also just wanted to note uh uh
uh the the news that we heard from the
ceo fox this morning that uh cameraman
pierre zagrewski i just want to
pronounce his name the right way did i
pronounce it the right way okay um lost
his life he is someone who
has served in many war zones
over the course of time he was a war
zone photographer who covered nearly
every international story for fox news
from iraq to afghanistan to syria during
his long tenure working there so we just
our thoughts our prayers are with his
family with the entire community as well
um so let me stop there um and let's
kick it off chris okay so uh
president's lunch is gonna be speaking
to congress tomorrow he's before five
years unknown zone yeah here's some of
the things tomorrow as well
as destruction thinking shift than that
at all and also
there is rising domestic pressure for
the us to do more uh how does the
president plan to continue being like a
voice of restraint in these situations
and holding back some of those requests
well first i i don't think the president
views himself as a voice of restraint we
have provided and he has approved and
expedited the delivery of uh more
assistance military and security
assistance to ukraine than any year in
history and i did a bit of an outline
for you at the beginning 1.2 billion
dollars in assistance that including 300
million that we've been able to get to
ukrainian fighters helping them to hold
back the russian military over the past
few weeks uh it is also true and there
will be more that the president will be
able to say over the next few days given
he is about to sign a 13.6
an omnibus bill that includes 13.6
billion dollars in security assistance
so i expect he will share more of those
details in the next 24 hours it is also
true that the president has to look at
decisions that are made through the
prism of what is in our national
security interests and global security
interests and he continues to believe
that a no-fly zone uh would be
escalatory could prompt a war with
russia i don't believe there's a lot of
advocates calling for that at this point
in time from capitol hill but we
certainly understand and recognize that
is still a call from uh president
zielinski and uh on covet i'm getting
your push for more funding there uh is
this assignment administration is
worried that the u.s could see a rise in
numbers like we've seen in europe and
his administration considering
advising americans to get another
booster
well any uh decision or recommendation
about a booster shot would be made by
the cdc but as we've said from the
beginning we always want to be prepared
for any scenario that may come up right
and we have also said that
while we have made an enormous amount of
progress in
in vaccinating americans and getting
americans boosted in providing uh free
masks and free tests to people across
the country uh that we are still uh
continuing to fight the pandemic and if
we wait too long we are not going to be
able to continue a lot of the programs
that are so effective and just to give
you some more specifics we are going to
run out of our supply of monoclonal
antibodies by june we will be unable to
maintain our testing capacity beyond
june we can't uh purchase additional
courses of evocheld and our existing
supply will likely run out this is for
this is a treatment for the
immunocompromised by the end of 2022.
the fund that reimburses doctors and
other medical providers for caring for
uninsured individuals will be scaled
back this month and end in early april
so those are just some of the examples
of where the american people could be
deeply impacted if we don't get funding
from congress there is not a secret plan
there is not another option we need
money in order to continue to supply
these programs and one last thing sorry
just back up the ukraine thing yeah you
said obviously no fly zone is escalatory
but i noticed you do not send it by the
fighter jet requests uh is that
something that nothing has changed about
the analysis that the department of
defense provided last week where they
assessed that um because of the
challenges in delivery and the
challenges uh and and the impact that
providing these would have would
be
greater risk than there would be benefit
and i would note that the way that the
president and the department of defense
and our experts here have been
responding to this uh conflict is by
providing the type of military and
assistance assistance and equipment that
has the ukrainians have used to push
back and to fight and effectively do
that over the last 19 days and that is
what we will continue to provide uh with
the additional funding in the omnibus go
ahead
one i guess the housekeeping matter on
the
remarks tomorrow from zalenski does the
president plan to watch and will we have
a response to his address
i'm sure that uh to the degree the
president can with his schedule he'll
certainly be watching as we all will be
um he gave a powerful pennsylvania a
very powerful set of remarks today and
when he spoke uh canada uh to the
canadians i should say and we certainly
expect that to be faced tomorrow and on
the ukrainian security assistance there
are concerns that people could possibly
try to to target uh or strike a delivery
of american military supplies how
concerned are you about this and how
confident are you that this assistant
will ultimately reach its intended
estimate i would say that obviously
they've been in the middle of a war zone
the past few weeks and we've still been
able to deliver 300 million dollars in
uh security assistance just over the
last two weeks and we believe we will
continue to have the means to do that
and has the president been discussing
with other nato leaders how they would
respond if putin were to strike
a delivery of american military supplies
inside poland and just so i'm clear
about what would happen in this instance
would a strike in poland on
supplies or anything really uh
automatically be met with a military
forceful response or simply a
conversation amongst allies about how to
respond well again typically there is a
conversation before you do a coordinated
response right um but i would say
without getting into a hypothetical we
have a range of conversations that
happen through a lot of channels
including military and defense channels
including diplomatic channels as we
prepare for a range of contingencies
go ahead
um american families are preparing for
summer vacations right now
often require travel by far long
distances
um what kind of guidance does the white
house have i mean should they expect or
plan for four dollar gasoline come
summer is there like a i know you guys
are concerned about the price but is
there a sense of urgency to get
something done before the summer months
which are really critical for a number
of reasons for driving sure look i think
the president and our national security
team and our economic team are working
overtime right now to
to evaluate and examine a range of
domestic options that that continue to
be on the table and also to engage with
global suppliers about what can be done
to ensure that the supply and the market
meets the demand thus bringing the price
down so um it is there are certainly
urgency uh there are certainly a need to
do everything we can to ensure we're
mitigating the impact
a bipartisan group of lawmakers have
called on the white house to lift the
ban of summer sales of gasoline
with higher blends of ethanol
it's cheaper than traditional
blends of gasoline is that something you
mentioned
a menu of options but is that something
specifically that the white house is
considering in the menu of options
um any comment on maryland uh moving
towards a suspension there's states a
gas loan tax
there are a number of other states who
have taken that step again there's
there's uh there's a range of domestic
options uh i would note that from the
federal standpoint the gasoline tax is
about 18 cents right so we're also
looking at a range of options that might
have different types of impacts you
brought up the 18 cents that is that
because i mean
it wouldn't have much of an impact at 18
cents if you've given it at 4.50
is that a fair read
of how you guys assess that not a
mathematician but um you know given that
uh that um the price of gas has gone up
by 75 cents a dollar
even more in some areas
we're continuing to look at a range of
options and obviously
ensuring that there is or taking steps
to ensure there's more supply in the
market because the oil market is a
global market uh is a big priority and a
focus for us but we're looking at a
range of domestic options including all
of the ones you mentioned just no
decision has been made at this point in
time go ahead caitlin thanks jen you
confirmed president biden is going to
brussels next week he's going to attend
the nato summit in the european council
meeting is he also going to go to poland
as has been reported we don't have
anything more yet about his trip to
announce should we expect anything when
it comes to the refugee crisis aspect of
what's been going on we're still working
through the final details of the trip um
and what it may look like but i don't
have any more details at this point in
time and what is his goal going into
this trip and is there any chance that
he sees president zielinski while he's
there
uh his goal is to meet in person face to
face with his european counterparts and
talk about and assess where we are at
this point in the conflict uh in uh the
invasion of ukraine by russia uh we've
been incredibly aligned uh to date that
doesn't happen by accident the
president's a big believer in
face-to-face diplomacy so it's an
opportunity to do exactly that in terms
of a meeting with president zelinski or
engage with president zielinski we're
still finalizing the trip at this point
in time but that's an option nothing on
the table at this point in time but the
real focus right now is to meet with
nato partners in brussels if there are
additional steps we'll share all those
details with all of you and on president
ozil if he's addressed tomorrow of
course he is expected to ask for more
assistance as my colleague noted a lot
of the u.s positions on that haven't
changed as you just said when it comes
to the knife no fly zone but on the
aircraft specifically the pentagon said
last week that secretary austin said
they do not support the transfer of
additional fighter aircraft at this time
is that still the united states position
that continues to be our position i
would note that they also said that uh
the that adding aircraft to the
ukrainian inventory is not likely to
significantly change the effectiveness
of the ukrainian air force relative to
russian capabilities and the assessment
was that the transfer of these uh planes
may be mistaken as escalatory as you
said and could result in a significant
russian reaction but that is the risk
assessment that was done that risk
assessment has not changed i would note
that uh certainly we expect as he should
president zolensky to ask for more money
we have we are in touch with his team on
a daily basis we're not waiting to we're
not waiting to hear tomorrow what may be
on his mind we are very closely engaged
with the ukrainians uh and that what
what is uh what hopefully will be of
interest to him is uh the significant
amount of security assistance that is in
the omnibus that we'll be able to detail
soon
has he told the white house what he
plans to ask for tomorrow that's not
what i'm suggesting but the president
had a nearly hour-long call with him on
friday and we talked with his team every
day thank you go ahead ash you mentioned
before the president stalinski gave an
extremely powerful set of remarks
to canada and you expect something
similar tomorrow to congress i was
wondering if you could talk about how
the administration plans to handle that
sort of very emotional appeal where we
expect him to be asking for certain
things which president biden has already
made clear he's not willing to provide
well i think that one what is
encouraging in this moment of tragedy is
that there is bipartisan support for the
strength and the courage of ukrainian
leadership and uh and president
zielinski and the fight that they have
been waging for the last 19 days
i would say that without knowing what
he's going to say tomorrow we certainly
are familiar with what the asks have
been we have provided our own assessment
of what does make sense and doesn't make
sense and what i would note is that we
do have a range
of the president and the our team has
fought for additional assistance in the
omnibus package the president is signing
this afternoon which hopefully we'll
have more details on uh in the coming
days
go ahead thank you again and to follow
up on that zolensky and other ukrainian
officials have made so clear that what
they believe they need the most
is more warplanes and fighter jets so
why
is the u.s assessing
something different
why does the us believe they know better
what nasa means than what ukrainian
officials are saying they need the most
well we have one of the best militaries
in the world i would note just some
factual details here the ukrainian air
force has several squadrons of fully
mission capable aircraft
and although russian air capabilities
are significant their effectiveness has
been limited due to the ukrainian
strategic operational and tactical
ground-based and air defense systems
which the united states has provided the
vast majority of so what we're talking
about here is what is most effective in
combating and fighting the type of war
the russians are fighting we've talked a
little bit about um the attack on uh uh
near the polish border
that would not have been stopped by
airplanes that that type of attack is
stopped by exactly the type of
assistance we've provided
okay so it's a combination of impact as
well as potential risks that the
administration has decided no
on the warp
exactly exactly and the fact that the
air force has several squadrons of fully
mission capable aircraft the 1.2 billion
dollars in military assistance that
we've provided has provided exactly the
type of capabilities that have helped
them fight back and push back
effectively and courageously against uh
the inbound attacks from uh the russian
military and as you also noted rija
there the the risk associated
is also something that our u.s military
would assess as part of their analysis
and then to follow up on mary's question
how does the us define a russian
incursion or invasion into nato
territory
that's a conversation we have with our
nato partners and allies so as an
example
there are reports that a russian drone
made its way into uh polish airspace
before going back to ukraine and being
shot down does a drone into poland
count as
an invasion again right
what happens here it's not that nato
countries just respond on their own if
there is uh a an attack or an uh that
that is considered by by nato leadership
and by nato countries to be uh to to
meet that that bar then there's a
discussion about among nato partners
about how to respond but it's not in
anyone's interest to get into an
escalatory war with russia
today by russia against yourself
president biden and other top u.s
officials um do you ever respond to that
and how will it impact any of you if at
all sure i would first note that
president biden is a junior
so
they may have sanctioned his dad may he
rest in peace um the second piece i
would say is that surprise many of you
uh that none of us are planning a tour
stripped to russia none of us have bank
accounts that we won't be able to access
so we will forge ahead
go ahead thanks dan um following up on
the drone question from ouija
the soviet-era drone that flew over
three nitto member states on friday and
then crashed into croatia has it been
determined whether that was a russian
drone or ukrainian drone
and
how do you measure similar to what she
was asking how do you measure
you know what elicits a response
well the for the second part of your
question jackie good question it is a
conversation that happens between nato
allies and partners not not not a
decision that's made by one uh country
uh in terms of the first part i don't
have any details that i can outline for
you from here and what to make of china
today warning that
taiwan belongs to china
and saying that it will not stop normal
trade relations with russia what what
qualifies as helping russia evade
sanctions when it comes to china well
let me note that one of the one of the
um during the lengthy conversation that
our national security adviser had uh
with uh with uh his counterpart he also
conveyed reiterated our one china policy
based on the taiwan relations act three
communiques and six assurances and
underscored concerns about beijing's
coercive and provocative actions across
the taiwan's rate which is of course our
position publicly but is also something
that he took the time to reiterate
during this conversation
there are a range of uh of sanctions we
obviously have in place and we we watch
of course if there's a violation of
those uh and we also watch if there is
support uh provided for the military
invasion of another country i don't have
any assessment of that to provide to you
today it sounds like secondary sanctions
are on the table if china is found to be
helping russia
either militarily or economically in
this war
so why not be specific about the kinds
of sanctions that we are considering
given that this administration's
position is the mere threat of sanctions
should be a deterrent
we're going to have those conversations
directly with china and chinese
leadership uh not through the media at
this point in time i would note that uh
when when our national security advisor
was having his meeting yesterday uh he
was very direct about the comp the
consequences uh he made clear we're
going to be watching closely made clear
that it's not just us the decisions that
china makes are going to be watched uh
by the world uh so that is how they
focus the meeting but in terms of any
potential impacts or consequences will
leave those through private diplomatic
channels at this point one last one on
zelinski tomorrow it sounds like you
know we're pretty dug in on our position
when it comes to the no-fly zone when it
comes to
the migs
despite this growing
call by person calling congress to shift
a little bit so to put it lightly is
zielinski wasting his time tomorrow
asking for these things
well i would say because of the passion
and the courage and the bravery of
president zielinski there has been
support for expediting the delivery of a
historic amount of military and security
assistance and weapons that have helped
him and his military fight back against
the russians and i would say that yes we
recognize there are a range of
bipartisan calls but what we have the
responsibility to do here is to assess
what the impact is on the united states
and our own national security a no-fly
zone is escalatory and could prompt a
war with russia a major nuclear power
providing the planes our military did an
assessment that's based not just on the
risk but whether it would have a huge
benefit to them they assessed it would
not because they have their own squadron
of planes and because the type of
military assistance that is working to
fight this war effectively is the type
of assistance we're already providing
what about estonia though calling for a
no-fly zone they're a nato
member they share a border with russia
how do we view their calls for a no-fly
zone we disagree
with the argument that that would be an
effective step because a no-fly zone
which often people shorthand essentially
means us shooting down russian planes
and them potentially shooting back at us
and i would note that the way that the
ukrainians again have effectively pushed
back over the last 19 days is by using
exactly the type of military assistance
we have provided go ahead kristen thank
you jen a couple of questions are there
discussions about the president meeting
with refugees in this trip to europe uh
it's a good question and obviously we
have provided and he'll talk about this
this afternoon historic amounts of
humanitarian assistance a great deal of
that focused on helping refugees there's
going to be more in this package but
there's we're not we don't have
additional details beyond what i just
announced at the top of the briefing
okay the follow-up on we just questioned
quickly
russia sanctioning various top officials
here i understand you're dismissing it
however does the administration does the
president see that as an escalation of
any kind
again i think we are confident that if
we need to have continued and we will
need to have direct and indirect
conversations with russia we will have
the ability to do that but it's related
to and i don't have anything official
aside from the reports i don't know how
their sanctioning process works i only
know how our sanctioning process works
but it relates to the impact typically
on bank accounts or travel that's not
diplomatic i want to ask you again about
the conversation about senators migs
former ambassador to ukraine marie
ivanovic has been quite outspoken
recently and she said we need to
mitigate risk but it's also true that
not taking greater action comes with a
risk as well because putin is a bully
and he only understands strength is the
president showing enough strength
against putin the president has rallied
the global community to put in place a
greater set of financial sanctions
package than has ever been done for any
economy in the world it wouldn't have
happened without his action i just
outlined for you at the top which i
think it's important to note the
crippling impact this has had on the
economy
we they are where they are at this point
in time i think we all have seen reports
and we have confirmed many of them that
uh they did not expect it to take this
long they did not expect uh their
military to not make as much progress as
they have made
the steps we are taking are making it
more difficult for president putin to
build and augment his military to get
access to the technology that he needs
and wants it has taken steps to [ __ ]
the economy that there's no question
regardless of what kremlin spokespeople
say it has had a dramatic impact on the
economy and we're doing all of that
while providing a historic amount of
military assistance to the ukrainians
helping them effectively fight back if
putin were to use chemical weapons would
it change the president's thinking when
it comes to these migs taking them off
lizard on the table but at least
i'm not going to get into a hypothetical
we of course there would be severe con
consequences from the global community
ones that we would discuss with our
partners and allies but i would note
that the planes would not have stopped
the attack we saw near the polish border
they have a squadron of planes and what
has effectively helped them fight back
is the types of military assistance that
they have been utilizing and are you
prepared can you give us any more
details about what that threat means of
severe consequences the president
obviously made the same threat last week
is that purely
economic consequences or would there
potentially be a military we're just not
going to outline in more detail from
here
go ahead
um i have a question about the fed sure
and senator manchin's opposition to
sarah bloom raskin will the white house
now support the senate moving ahead to
confirm the other fed nominees why do
they need to confirm all these nominees
at once
well i would say first that cerebellum
raskin is one of the most qualified
individuals ever to be nominated to
serve in this position we remain in
close touch
with both her and with chairman brown
about the next steps here but we have
continued to press and we have been
pressing for all five not just to be to
to be able to be voted on in the banking
committee where they have the votes to
move forward and that is where
republicans have not showed up to meet
quorum so uh at this point i don't have
an update beyond uh reiterating our
strong support for her
go ahead well the president himself
addressed uh bring up the dust um and
injuries of american journalists in
ukraine were killed in ukraine
well the president himself addressed the
deaths of americans um who have american
journalists who have been killed or
injured in ukraine and doesn't have any
plans to call their families
uh i'm not going to outline private
conversations from here at this point in
time um obviously these families are in
a
in a moment of mourning right now um and
so beyond that i think we're just
respecting their their space and time go
ahead
briefly just going back to covet funding
yeah um obviously this is something um
that white house officials stressed
today this is something that's
addressed in his state of the union
address um but if this is so important
for the president and the white house
will he meet with republicans indeed
individually uh will he make his case to
them personally i would note that
there's a number of republicans who
won't even return our phone calls about
the impact of the lack of coveted
funding and how they will impact their
constituents so that's probably the best
place to start go ahead yeah i have a
couple more questions on the path
related to the coveted funding um how
the heck are you going to get it through
congress
you have republicans in the senate who
are making it very clear leadership
saying that there is no republican
support for moving any more money for
covet relief because they believe
and i believe the bus hasn't made a
strong enough case that funds can't just
be moved around to
fund these priorities sure well we've
been making that case publicly and
privately back to earlier this year so
that those are the facts
we've also been as i just noted
attempting to engage with and have these
conversations with of course democrats
but also republicans covet doesn't
discriminate just by party
at all
i think what we're trying to do is uh
really be very clear and direct about
what the impacts will be i mean some of
these programs funding for uh for
treatments for immunocompromised
providing free tests and masks providing
free
boosters and vaccines
those will impact millions of americans
potentially in this country regardless
of their partisan affiliation so what
we're doing we're going to of course
leave the process in the vehicle up to
congress we we are encouraging them and
aggressively calling for them to move
these resources immediately and what
we've tried to do is break down what the
impacts are going to be on different
states and also when specific programs
will end so that it doesn't feel like
just a number but feels like a direct
impact on programs in people's lives in
terms of whether money can be moved
around i know you've said before that it
can't be moved around uh what we're
hearing from the hill is that they
believe there's about 100 million
dollars that could be shifted um and and
certainly there was an agreement with
the for leaders to shift funds that fell
apart in part because governors fault
but um
is there money that could be moved
do these dire consequences have to start
next week or could funds be shifted and
then later allergies well the opposition
as you know it prevented that from
happening a portion of what moved
forward right i don't know that that
opposition has changed um at this point
in time um but also it's important to
note that um we believe that this should
be provided on an emergency basis
not something where there will require
offsets it shouldn't have to require
taking money from states who are using
it for um different programs whether
it's funding cops or police officers or
other programs that was a good decision
in the negotiation but not aware of any
change in the uh of support for that go
ahead domestic energy yeah has the white
house spoken to senator joe manchin
about his push uh to use to do more
domestic oil and gas production i know
that senator manchin has been interested
in the president using the dpa defense
production act to complete that pipeline
from west virginia to virginia that the
mountain valley pipeline is the white
house interested in that well we've
engaged with
a range of members democrats and
republicans including senator manchin
about a range of ideas they have that's
why so many things are on the table i
would note that the use of the defense
reduction act broadly speaking would
mean you're paying a company to do what
they already have the capacity and the
ability to do we know there are 9 000
unused and approved oil leases right now
that these oil companies could tap into
and do more in in terms of the building
of a pipeline that does not sound like
it's an immediate solve for what we're
seeing right now is an increase of cost
at the gas pump
go ahead
jan if i could walk you back for a
moment through the
logic train that you were trying to lay
out for us of the risk of sending
in that case the polish jets but in
general versus the rewards for it here
so if i understand it right the
president has determined that
giving
ukrainian pilots
these migs would
more directly involve the united states
in the conflict and therefore that's
what creates the high risk is that right
well david it's not the president's
assessment or certainly not my
assessment it was the assessment by the
department of defense and a big part of
their assessment was related to where
these planes would take off from and how
would you get them into ukraine so that
was something we were uh exploring and
discussing uh with a range of partners
um but um their assessment was also was
based specifically on the transfer of it
to ukraine and that that uh may be
mistaken as
escalatory the fact that they would take
off from a polish base even a base in
germany under paul
makes that base a a legitimate military
target and they don't want to take that
risk well i wouldn't say would say
legitimate but but that it could be
perceived as escalatory yes so on the
other side of this we are transferring
any aircraft
equipment to that yeah it's got to
originate someplace in the west right
somehow it's got to get in place what's
the distinction
we're able to move a lot of that
equipment in a way that is not taking
off from a nato air base without getting
into specifics of how it's transferred
it's originating from the west in some
way correct and that's known yes
there are some other possibilities of
things you could be providing them with
for example you mentioned that the
missile strike
uh near the polish border wouldn't have
really been helped by the yeah i think
that we're all in agreement with that um
you could imagine a series of
shorter-range anti-missile systems like
what we give to the
provider and the manufacturer in israel
to
to ward off incoming short-range missile
is there discussion of that kind of
anti-missile system to prevent exactly
what you see yeah it's a good question
david you probably know more about
military equipment than anyone except
for the department of defense so here we
are but look i would i would really
those discussions happen at the
department of defense they consider and
we've talked a lot about the risk
assessment as it relates to the planes
but they make assessments about what to
provide to be most effective as they
provide any range of military equipment
again as you know there's a big portion
of the omnibus which we'll be able to
detail more soon that will be security
assistance just like there's economic
and humanitarian assistance and i'm sure
we'll have more details on what will be
included in there and one last one are
you encouraging any of our other nato
allies including turkey to do these
kinds of transfers
well i think
oh sorry the the second piece of
military equipment you mentioned look
there's a range of discussions as you
know among military counterparts and
defense counterparts about what
equipment is needed who has that
equipment how to provide it uh but i
don't have more to detail that
would solve a particular running problem
that
you've had since you were
yeah from the podium at the state
department uh is there any particular
discussion underway with turkey on this
year i just don't have more details on
that for you i'm happy to check if
there's more go ahead karen um is there
a plan for the president to talk to
president zielinski before he delivers
those remarks tomorrow to congress
uh i'm happy to check i'm not there's
not a call currently on the schedule he
just spoke with him last friday but
again our national security adviser a
range of officials here are in touch
with uh with senior members of their
national security team every day i know
you said the president's gonna of course
be talking about the 13.6 billion
dollars in age ukraine when he gives
remarks in a few minutes you said
earlier that uh the united states is
working to get ukraine equipment as
quickly as possible can you walk us
through the timeline on the 13.6 how
quickly will that get out is it going
out all at once are there stages
what's the plan for that i expect we'll
have more on that in the next 24 to 48
hours i understand the question we're
looking forward to detailing it for you
go ahead thanks jen yesterday the
president spoke again about his desire
to see legislation passed aimed at
lowering costs of prescription drugs and
child care can you provide an update on
the white house's conversations with
senate democrats about passing narrowly
tailored legislation that would include
those programs and others that the
president again said would ease
inflationary pressures uh i would just
say that we found and we made the
determination after last fall that
keeping those conversations private is
the best way to hopefully make progress
and so we're engaged in a daily basis
with conversations with senate democrats
committee members staff about how to
move this forward is i think you know
and others know who talk to members
there's a lot of excitement and
enthusiasm for getting these things done
specifically lowering the cost of
prescription drugs what the president
wants to do is have as much of the
package included as there can be 50
votes for but we're going to leave those
conversations to happen through private
channels a lot of them happening member
to member on the hill any sense of
timing of when that can happen with the
april recess coming up soon again i'm
just not going to provide an update from
here because
we feel that
these talks are best are best kept
between members and and kept between
conversations we have with our staff in
them sure and speaking of senate
democrats the senate judiciary committee
will hold its hearings next week
president's supreme court nominee how is
the white house preparing for those
hearings and specifically how is it
preparing judge jackson for the scrutiny
that she could come under from
republicans who sit on that committee
well first judge jackson i think as
you've seen has been meeting with
working to meet with every member on the
committee before her hearing and made a
great deal of progress on exactly that
i think you could i would note that
you've heard members come out senators
come out
of who agree with us on very little
who've come out and conveyed that she's
qualified and that they had good
conversations with her so that's part of
it
as soon as she was nominated she started
uh practicing and studying and preparing
which i don't think surprises anyone
who's looked at her impeccable
credentials and record to date and i
expect that will continue until she
starts the hearings early next week go
ahead jen
on the refugee crisis from ukraine is
there any conversation about the role
the u.s could play to alleviate some of
the burden felt by poland for example
either something similar to what we set
up coming out of afghanistan airlifting
people expediting processing especially
for those who have family members in the
u.s sure um
we are having ongoing internal
discussions about how we can uh play the
most effective role in supporting the
large number of refugees who are coming
out of ukraine
to date that has been as you know an
enormous amount of humanitarian
assistance that we're providing not just
to ukraine but to neighboring countries
that are providing a haven for refugees
as they're leaving ukraine in terms of
other discussions i just can't outline
those at this point in time but we are
we are continuing to discuss what
options there are there are
conversations about helping ukrainians
come to america as well we're discussing
the president
would welcome ukrainians coming here
obviously they currently they could
apply through the refugee process but
we're continuing to discuss what options
may exist
over the weekend the cdc end title 42
restrictions for unaccompanied minors
and a couple of reasons they gave were
the larger public health conditions but
also that appropriate mitigation
measures had been put into place in the
care facilities yeah so is the
administration asking dhs to put those
same mitigation measures in place in
other detention facilities so you can
end title 42 for everyone well any
decision made by the cdc about ending
title 42 would have would once they make
the decision it would have to be
implemented to your appointment by dhs
and other components of the interagency
that
oversee these facilities and ensure that
they're meeting the bars that would be
required
but the first step would really be cdc
making a decision about ending it for
other populations go ahead thanks jen
two topics first the prime ministers of
poland czech republic in slovenia went
to kiev today is that why does have any
comment on that you know would an
american administration officially make
a similar trip or conversely is there a
concern that's security risk where
something were to happen to them then
that could be an escalation with nato
members
well
we certainly uh hope that is not the
outcome um we uh respect the role
they're playing in diplomacy right now
and obviously going directly into the
middle of a war zone shows their strong
support for president zielinski for the
ukrainian military for ukrainians um and
we certainly support that and i'm
certain we will engage with them
following their trip as a follow-up as
we have been doing with other leaders
who have engaged with the ukrainians and
the russians
in terms of any step or trip uh by a
member of the national security team or
others i don't have anything to predict
for you uh at this point in time uh but
uh you know we will continue to assess
whether that would be constructive or
help move things in a positive direction
on another matter uh there are a few
more members of the house
representatives who tested positive for
covid today yeah adding to some
over the weekend to do the same many of
whom were democrats at the retreat on
friday where they saw the president uh
not many masks worn has the president
been tested for kovitz since uh and are
there any concerns about exposures he
may have uh he was tested on sunday and
he tested negative um all of the members
to date prior to today and i'm happy to
double check the specific piece we're
not deemed as close contacts uh they are
all vaccinated as well so the cdc
wouldn't recommend a change in behavior
as a result um but uh he had received a
negative test just a couple days ago go
ahead
on oil suppliers
canada has been looking at
increasing its flow of crude oil can you
confirm that conversation has been
happening between the administration and
the canadian government
i know we've been closely engaged with
canada about a range of issues in terms
of the specifics of a conversation about
oil and crude i'd have to check with our
team in on that
there's been a report yesterday about
the possibility that india could take up
the russian offer of uh discounted crude
oil what would be your uh message to
india or any other country tempted by
such an option well our message to and
to any country continues to be that uh
obviously abide by the sanctions uh but
that we we have put in place and
recommended i don't believe this would
be violating that but also think about
where you want to stand uh when when the
history books are written in this moment
in time and
support for
the russian leadership is support for
an invasion that obviously is having a
devastating impact go ahead thank you
jen there's reporting that saudi arabia
is considering accepting the yen instead
of the dollar for chinese oil is the
white house monitoring that possibility
and has the administration communicated
that there would be any types of
consequences if that happened let me
check with the treasury department on it
it's a good question i hadn't seen the
report i'll check with them and then
could you speak to
the urgency for getting this additional
code funding from congress at a moment
when it seems that a lot of the
attention and focus has been on moving
away from the pandemic
sure well even as we have focused on
conveying we have
that we're in a different stage um and
we have a range of the tools in order to
fight the pandemic in order to continue
our capacity of having those tools we
need money and we've always uh
planned um been what we have done
effectively is planned ahead right
ensuring that if we get to a point we've
seen obviously va2 which we've talked
about a bit in here um which i think as
of yesterday was about 25 to a third of
the cases here
very transmissible but treatable by all
the means that we have
we need to have masks tests
boosters
treatments for immunocompromise in order
to continue to
treat uh treat the pandemic or treat the
american people during a pandemic so it
remains urgent if we don't get uh this
funding we won't be able to um ensure we
have can provide free access to the
american people go ahead
just to confirm the us and allies we're
publicly arming the ukrainians but we're
deliberately avoiding
shipping from nato countries to ukraine
that's not what i said what i said was
uh planes taking off from a nato uh base
our department of defense assessed that
that would be a step that would be
escalatory as they were making a risk
assessment
from nato bases
okay up planes
via planes but ground is another
i'm not going to give you detail or
confirm where our military equipment
moves from for obvious reasons because
our objective is to provide that to the
ukrainians
these tragic you know deaths of
journalists that you mentioned is there
any reason to conclude that the russians
are deliberately targeting them
we have seen from the beginning
that they have targeted um
hospitals they've targeted journalists
um in terms of these individual cases i
can't make an assessment of that from
here
but certainly we've seen um you know
barbaric and um horrific actions by the
military on the ground and this is
consistent with that
go ahead so aside from the request for
weapons president zielinski has also
requested that the us be more involved
in negotiations toward the peaceful
resolution
to the war what is the us doing to push
those negotiations forward
well one of the steps we've taken a
significant one is to be the largest
provider of military and humanitarian
and economic assistance in the world to
put them in a greater position of
strength as they go into these
negotiations we also engage and talk to
the ukrainians on a daily basis and the
president and this national security
team has has rallied the world in being
unified in their opposition to the
actions of president putin so those are
the steps we're taking we also engage uh
oftentimes before and after any
conversations that any of these uh
global leaders are having with both
russians and ukrainians encourage them
to make sure they're engaging with
ukrainians directly would zelensky be
empowered by the united states to
reach an agreement with russia and have
u.s sanctions
released as a result well he's the
leader of ukraine so he's empowered to
have a negotiation with russia and we're
here to support those efforts
again i'm not going to get ahead of a
negotiation but we are here to support
those efforts we discuss and have
conversations with him with his team on
a daily basis go ahead george yeah let
me ask you about thursday's meeting
between the president and the irish
t-shirt
yeah best in the area
does the white house view that as in any
way a sign that we're getting back to
normal after two years of cancelled
meetings canceled parades and last year
having to do it virtually sure well um
the president is very much looking
forward to welcoming the taoiseach here
on thursday to celebrate saint patrick's
day
we have started to have some events
where there are more people
where there is
some food or beverage served and
certainly this will be a
continuation of that and
while we are still taking steps and
precautions here in the white house
including regular testing um this is
certainly a step uh that we welcome uh
being able to uh to invite uh
our friends into to celebrate on
thursday
go ahead and oh yeah so china
gathers in go ahead okay yeah quickly
going back to china um so right now
you're saying that china and the chinese
companies are not breaking sanctions by
doing normal economic relations
i did not provide an update or an
assessment of that from here and nor do
i have one to provide you without
talking about red lines what would the
u.s need to see
for them for that to be a breaking of
the sanctions i understand your question
i'm just not going to outline it from
here we watch closely the world is
watching closely and
our national security advisor was clear
there will be consequences should they
uh should they violate
our sanctions thank you everyone so much
[Music]